SCARLETT JOHANSSON
How much do you really know about
the elusive Natasha Romanoff?
NATASHA ROMANOFF
Before I worked for S.H.I.E.L.D.,
I made a name for myself.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
When it was time to assemble the Avengers,
who did S.H.I.E.L.D. call?
NATASHA ROMANOFF
Let me put you on hold.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
A former KGB assassin,
agent of
S.H.I.E.L.D, and Avenger,
she fought through
the Battle of New York...
...squared off
against the Winter Soldier...
...defended
the world against Ultron.
She signed
the Sokovia Accords...
...dealt with all that fallout.
And beat back
the forces of Thanos.
And when all seemed lost,
she held the team together.
But... How well do you really
know her? It's time for her story.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
I've lived a lot of lives.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
You've been waiting for this.